[Music]
why does it feel like a but you know
what promise [ __ ] your bear be honest
wait am I longing that waiting for
sure's to drop it this multi have you
can't copy is premeditated depending on
topic you think is four by the way I'll
be mixing these flows like Jim platonic
is why ironic you came through a few and
left with more filament - don't say
you're an angel go stop it
shelling everything that I touch like
Mario you got a skin fading you still
didn't smudge for a walk one there don't
say you are like an ocean you can
naturally can't be mine Hotel a
percentage is law so I gotta go I just
want to fine-tune so I can get gas when
I drop that pass on a trainer
[Music]
[Music]
trying to get one focus was like Ramadan
only compared to a bag of my flesh are
smoking after our palms get drop like
ugly amazing you said you'd better wish
you could backtrack locked in on a
cassette now I've got replica
fiber-optic cable shield interracial
x-rated content straight to your mum's
up no car [ __ ] with one sucka for and
this one tooth will turn into
astrologist me on my thighs read books
you should pick up a few get the gist is
last whether knowledge is followed his
truck and shot with a popular at 24
billboquet catch the album honor it but
the DS handouts on on your scholarship
finger your polish kit
[Music]